i'm passing the phone to a person who  don't play defense i'm passing the phone  to someone who talks a lot of [ __ ] but  it's actually a softie i'm passing the  phone to a [ __ ] who says that she's  over her ex but really isn't passing the  phone to someone that passes standing up  i'm passing the phone to somebody who  always says come on even if we can't get  the ball i'm passing a phone to a person  who walks like a 12 year old i'm passing  the phone to someone who always acts  like she is hoes but really has no hope  i'm passing the phone to my pepper  partner i'm passing the phone to the  person who spends way too much money at  azda i'm passing the phone to someone  who thinks she's black because she's  from detroit but who also thinks the  best rapper is eminem i'm passing the  phone to the person who's always rocking  the little pony i'm passing the phone to  the hottest girl on this team  hello how are you